If we had a binomial or trinomial in these denominators, we would want to factor
them first. But since these are monomials, we can use our factor tree method to
figure out what they share. I know 9 and 15 share a common factor of 3, and the
a's share a common factor of 1a. The highest power of b that's in common is b
squared. So 3ab squared is my greatest common factor. The other factor for this
denominator is 3a squared. If we multiply these two together, we'll get our
original denominator. Whereas for this fraction, the missing factor is 5b
squared, if I multiply these two together we'll get 15, 3 times 5, a, and then b
squared times b squared or b to the fourth. We multiply all these factors
together to get our LCD. So our lowest common denominator is 3 times 3 times 5,
which is 45 and then a squared time a which is a cubed, and b squared times b
squared which b to the fourth. I said earlier that you want to use the highest
power of any factor for the lowest common denominator. Notice that we have a
cubed in a. A cubed is the highest power in either denominator. So we want to
make sure that appears in our LCD. Likewise between b squared and b to the
fourth, this fourth power is higher, so we know b to the fourth needs to appear
in our LCD. This is a quick way you can check to make sure your variables or
your factors are correct.